- [Voiceover] So I'm here with Amy Jarich,
who's the Director of Admissions
at the University of
California at Berkeley.
And my question to you is when you imagine
college admissions,
there's traditional notion
of you get a GPA.
You have to take certain
classes and all of these
to be "qualified."
Is that always the case, or
is there a path for students
who might not have a traditional GPA
or might not have all
the traditional classes?
- So I would say
particularly in selective admissions,
our job is not so much to
focus on the admit rate
and what those numbers
look like when you look
at the incoming profile,
much more to think
about who's a student who's
gonna graduate successfully
from our institution.
And I think if we're doing our job well,
we're finding those students,
and it means that to keep up
with the ways students learn
today, we have to look beyond
those traditional measures,
so we do look past GPAs.
We look beyond test scores.
In terms of the tools that we use,
we probably haven't tapped
into the very best ones
available yet, but we
do read their writing.
We look to see what extra
curriculars they're a part of.
There's never going to
be a personal statement
or an essay that trumps
the academic work though.
Really it's thinking about
academically, are you prepared
for a classroom like the one at Berkeley
or the one at Virginia or
the one at Stanford, right,
to make sure that you'll
succeed when you're there?
I think for us we really
have started to see students
who are branching out and
learning in different ways.
And they're leading us, right.
We're having to figure
out the ways to evaluate,
and we don't have a
whole lot of experience.
We certainly have
a whole group of schools in the Northeast
that are some of our
oldest secondary schools,
who haven't given a letter
grade, and that's fine.
We work with those, we always have.
We've worked with homeschool students
who typically bring us a different kind
of high school record, so we're learning.
But I do think that the process
of changing secondary education is slowly
also changing what we look at
and how we evaluate for success
once you get onto our campus.
- [Voiceover] You mentioned
academics are very important,
and I completely understand that,
but how would you evaluate
someone's academic potential
if they don't have a traditional GPA?
- So a lot of what we're gonna
rely on the school to provide
is something that articulates
in words or numbers,
letters, whatever it is,
the type of environment
the student is learning in,
what the core mastery is supposed to be,
and then just helping us
understand the evaluation scale
and where does the student
fall on that scale.
And I think sometimes that could be
in the form of a paragraph.
Sometimes it may be in
the form of a chart.
What we do now is
we read within context,
so it's not crazy to think
that we have to investigate
the way a school teaches
before we can make the
very best decisions about
how the learns in that school.
And that's something
that's our responsibility to do.
We're not in the business of building
secondary school curriculums, right.
We just need to learn what
type of curriculum you have
and how it's articulated to us in terms
of the measurement of success.
- [Voiceover] So you
all take a closer look
or as much context as you can
have on that particular school
that might be in some ways nontraditional.
And then there's also things
like standardized tests.
- Sure, so we have standardized tests.
Not all universities and colleges that use
selective admissions look for
standardized tests anymore,
but most still do.
In most cases, they're simply
validating something else
we see in the application though.
For most schools, they're
not the decision maker.
They're showing us that,
"Oh look, this student is strong in math.
"Let's look at the SAT.
"Yup, turns out they're strong
(interviewer laughs)
"in math."
Right, there's no big surprise.
Every once in a while there's a gap,
and that sometimes leads to
really good conversations
in our own environment
about why that happens.
Is it test prep?
Is it test anxiety?
We have a provost at Berkeley
who's worked quite strongly
in talking about the stereotype
threats and the whole idea
that when you walk into a
space, someone has already
prejudged the way you behave.
And standardized test is usually
the lab they use to show that,
so we talk about that when there's a gap,
but usually standardized tests
just validates what we see
elsewhere in that academic
profile of the student.
- [Voiceover] And there these notions
of approved curricular.
Correct me if I'm wrong.
Especially here in California,
I think there's something
to the effect of A to B, or there's some A
to some type of,
- [Amy] G.
- [Voiceover] A to G, A to G.
What are those things,
and how strictly are those enforced
that you have to somehow align to that?
- Sure so the university
system in California is really
aligned, and it's been aligned
through the master plan
that was developed in the 60s
to be able to allow students
to build a path and stay in California,
starting in the secondary
school and moving up.
So the UC system, as the
most selective public school
system in the state,
is looking to make sure
that the curriculum in the high school is
allowing the student to get the best prep.
To do that, the UC system for years
has actually evaluated
the curriculum of a high school.
So a high school, if they
come up with a new course,
they need to submit it to the
UC system to get approval.
And then when the application
is being filled out
by the student, they'll see
that course is UC approved.
Do we admit students from
schools that don't have
UC-approved coursework?
Absolutely.
Think about all of the
out-of-state students
that are applying, none of them have
UC-approved coursework, right.
So we are certainly thinking outside
of that A through G box, but
we use the A through G language
to help people understand
what the college prep path
in California looks like.
And the only way we can
make sure it's consistent
is having a system that
evaluates each course.
A bit like standardized testing, right,
there's something about it
that feels standardized,
so that you can trust
it a little bit more.
- [Voiceover] Yeah.
And you have, as you
mentioned, it could be
out-of-state students who
obviously weren't participating
in the A to G requirements,
and some of those might
even be nontraditional.
Might not have
- [Amy] Right, of course.
- [Voiceover] a traditional GPA.
- Yeah.
And we also see a lot of students now.
One of the hardest questions,
particularly for students
out of state, I think
right now, when they think
about A through G, it includes art.
So if you're a student who
is incredibly interested
in being admitted to one of
Berkeley's STEM programs,
particularly engineering,
you have the opportunity
to take a second year of
physics at an advanced level
or complete the A through G requirements
by taking art, what am I supposed to say?
I want you to take the physics, right.
I want you to have that background.
I believe in art, course I do.
I know why it's a part of A through G,
but for that student's development
and that student's interest,
that A through G equation
just doesn't fit.
As we adjust to see what
students are learning
and how they're learning
and what are the topics
that are most interesting
to them, we're just evolving
in the admissions process
to be able to meet them
where they are.
And I'll be honest, we're
little bit behind, right.
There plenty of schools
that challenge us with
the way that they teach
or what they're teaching.
But when those students come to our campus
as admitted students, and
they choose to attend,
they're the ones who go to faculty hours.
They're the ones who understand the value
of having lab time and
doing hands-on activities
and research, and I think
that's a really important part
of the college experience.
They don't have to
spend quite as much time
building up that confidence
level in whether or not
they should go to talk to the teacher
or whether or not they
could possibly participate
in hands-on learning.
- [Voiceover] Yeah and
so your general sense,
and obviously it's hard to
make overbroad statements.
But a student, nontraditional
school or background,
maybe doesn't have traditional GPA,
but they're able to show that
their academic capabilities,
maybe it's through standardized
tests or they take some
other types of exams, they
can show that they are
of the caliber that you all would expect,
so that they could come
and do well at a place
like Berkeley, and they
also show other things.
They made cool projects, or they have
really great portfolios of work.
That's something that you
all take a serious look at.
- Yeah.
Through our process, we
actually ask the student
to articulate that.
So in their personal
statement, they might talk
about an internship that
they had and why it mattered,
what they did.
Other schools actually might
have a letter of recommendation
process or a portfolio review process
where they'll look at the
things that were developed,
or they'll hear the voice of the person
who was this individual's
supervisor or mentor.
And I think that's an
important piece of any type of
less than traditional model because
relying on a student
who has only known that model
to explain everything that's unique
and cool about it doesn't make
a lot of sense, right.
You need someone from
the outside perspective
to be able to compare and
contrast to maybe the way
that they were educated and understanding
that student's story is very
different and very powerful
in a modern way.
- Yeah, well thank you so much.
This is really valuable.
- [Amy] Yeah, of course!
(laughter)
Happy to help.